the megan the stallion cameo
oh you are way more fun than my last
lawyer i will kill for you megan
solid back did you shoot with her i did
and it was you know the best day of my
life it was so great i was i'm a massive
fan of hers and when jessica told me
that was a thing that she had written
into the script i nearly died like i
just couldn't even deal with it well i
didn't get to shoot with meghan the
stallion we obviously all snuck onto set
that day
and it was remarkable we were really
kind of campaigning to get her on the
show jamila knows her so that was very
helpful i was just in shock when i met
her like she's so cool and she's so
interesting and then someone reminded me
that she was 26 and i was just like what
did you have a torque double for that
you're the first person in the mcu to
have a torque double i wish i could say
it wasn't me baby but it was me that was
you know it was me but but of course you
know then vfx takes it and makes it very
good
yeah no it's amazing i feel like uh
captain america might have a new
competition he should get that button
involved yeah
bucky
[Music]
that is america's ass
he doesn't drop it low he will
if he knows it's good for him yeah if
he's if he knew what was on the line
right but she's really like this regal
smart wonderful actor and really funny
and and just like powerful like what a
fascinating person an artist to see and
titanium for me that she did not need a
torque double no she didn't and i hope
they released behind the scenes because
the dancing was much longer and tatiana
came to sleigh and goodness she's a
freaking amazing dancer like i don't
know what she gets on all fours she's
twerking it's amazing so if i have to
leak it i will
[Music]
i'm not proud of this talk to me about
getting the tone of this right and you
know the breaking the fourth wall and
just the humor aspect of it how did you
know when you were like dialed in and
nailing it uh never never knew that
but um but the script it was so funny
when i read it like the pilot when i
read it for the audition i was just like
i was laughing on every page and i found
it so relatable and kind of
embarrassingly human and that to me is
where like some of the great comedy
comes from is like these very real
characters who are like on this backdrop
of a huge marvel universe you know that
collision of like superhuman and just
like regular dude is really fun and the
direct-to-camera stuff
has been done so many times so well and
and so i definitely like watched a lot
of that and took from flea bag and like
ferris bueller and all these great
references but also there's something
about jen that's like you guys are my
buddies come into my brain and let's
like go on this journey together like
she's hyper aware of the audience and
she's sort of looking back at them which
is fun so talk about the juxtaposition
of having jen have a career when we meet
her like a successful career and then
having these super powers and having
like the interplay between her personal
life and her super hero life yeah i feel
like there would come a moment where jen
might even be like a little bit jealous
of she-hulk in a way i think you hit the
nail on the head i think there's
something about she-hulk that commands
like an attention and not a respect
necessarily but definitely a like less
of a condescension than she experiences
as jen when she has done so much work to
get to where she is as a lawyer and
she's
so smart and so driven
but as soon as she hulk enters the room
like nobody cares about jen which of the
avengers do you think jen would like to
defend in court which would you like to
see jen defend i would love to defend
bruce i would love to defend i think
that would be super fun but we keep
talking about baby groot oh my gosh just
because of that the discrepancy between
a baby group and her like seriously
defending this little buddy because what
what did this little guy do
that's what i want to know he's very
little he gets up to all kinds of
youtubers get all kinds of yes at some
point he's going to break an american
law he will break an american law and
then he must be taken to port
imagine a little tiny tree i love it
now that we're introducing all these
like incredible actresses playing these
incredible
superheroes would you like to see an a
force team up would you like to see like
you and brie larson and florence and
haley like all kind of get together for
a mini series or a film yeah is this an
offer because that would be so much fun
it is i would love that yeah come on out
everybody we're shooting it right now
when you get facetime with kevin do you
pitch him ideas like that now that
you're in the world oh boy no way um i'm
j i we nerd out about movies when i talk
to kevin it's like we talk about movies
that we watch from like the 80s or the
you know horror movies in the 70s like
that's that's what we talk about i mean
i know you can't say much about it but
obviously daredevil has been teased
charlie cox are you guys going to see
each other in court is it just a street
fight maybe it's a little about
everything there's uh he's he's great
he's really great i think people are
gonna love this stuff between the two of
us were you at all disappointed when you
realize that jen has command of she-hulk
like pretty quick and didn't get to like
rampage and you know figure it out and
no i i love that because we've already
told that story of like not being able
to control your emotions or like not
being able to deal with them and i think
it is like very um astute that a woman
who is faced with this like massive
experience where her emotions
would take over her and she would lose
consciousness but actually she's just
very good at dealing with them because
she's been doing that her whole life
that that to me is a really smart
observation and super fun to play is
there a moment from a previous mcu film
that you would like to have seen jen in
hmm that's a really good question the
one scene i always think about is thor
hanging upside down in the beginning of
ragnarok not that i want jen to be there
but i just love that scene i would just
have loved to be on set for that day
because it totally that's insa like i
remember just being so blown away that
that they were doing that yeah like it
was just such a great reversal of you
know this sort of like god like yeah it
was great what was your reaction like
the first time you saw your face on
she-hulk's body it was amazing because
because the vfx is so good like it
really you really can see her breathing
and thinking and like blinking and like
it's not that like weird uncanny valley
thing like it's super
clearly a person and and
that to me was so bolstering it made me
feel like i could do
any amount of nuance and it would be
picked up by the vfx artist and they
would like make it clear you know what i
mean the tech is amazing yeah yeah there
i mean there are there's like there's
scenes where with your eyes you're like
explaining like the book of human laws
yeah yeah there's a little thing i was
like oh my god that's your face yeah
that's your face on that body even when
she-hulk is introduced to the public we
get a brief glimpse it's sort of this
like toxic male fandom that's just so
prevalent why was it important for you
guys to address that in the show i think
jessica knew that you know as soon as
there's a female superhero it's like
there's so much commentary on like why
her why a woman why not
why not
you know so she
foresaw what was gonna happen
when this show came out and so that like
the meta elements of this show and of
jessica's like ability to foresee how it
would be received uh it's it's exactly
it's like right in the the pocket of
she-hulk you know
[Music]
you